hello everyone and welcome back to the
Jerusalem grand prix 2019 it's Maxine
Rochelle a gravure tsa's whistlin top
all of two of their classical games have
been drawn and today we are going into
the tiebreak so they will be playing two
rapid games this is the first game of
the rapids and Maxime I chooses a very
nice line two of them already played
well not it's not that Maxime chose it
both of them go into a two of them
already played this game in the 2016
Norway championship and then Maxime
takes a different approach to the
position so we do have one photo again
courtesy of nicky riga for official
photographer of the feeder grand prix so
let's just enjoy it for a second there
you have it
it's from the classical game where
Veselin had the white pieces we don't
have the photos from the rapid yet but
you know just to get in the mood and
other than the fact that Veselin didn't
bring any refreshments to the game there
really isn't anything odd about this
photo so let's just you know enjoy it
that being said let's check out the game
so like I said the two of them already
played this game we have E 4 E 5 9 f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule
opus is on the board Knight if six top
olive goes for the Berlin defense with
castles and now Knight captures on e4
so we already covered this line there I
don't know how many times 96 Bishop
captures DT at rest and now D captures
on e5 the early Queen trade is on the
board tonight at 5 Queen capture screen
captures and now h3 and here the most
common move here is King to e8 but here
for this game to Paulo chooses the line
he already played against Maxime in the
2016 Norway Championship Bishop to d7
with rook to d1 and now Bishop to e7 so
all seen before when black plays the
Berlin g4 pushing the knight back and
not nice to age for a white trade and
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
Knight to e2 the night will now come to
f3 at e2 take the place of the other
night and kick away the bishop back to
e7 so here we have kink the c8 you don't
want to the Kingdom on the same file
here and this is again usual stuff in
the building defense you want to play b7
b 6 and see
five clear the light squares for your
light square bishop - maybe put the King
on b7 and get to the rook into the game
Knight to f3 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to e7 and now we get to the
position that two of them already had in
Norway in 2016 where Maxime played
Bishop to d3 that game ended in a draw
but here Maxine goes Bishop to g5 he
offers a trade of dark square bishop
it's not a new move it has been played
before but it's hard to say if the
pallav is you know they're familiar with
the position so to Paulo declines the
trade Bishop to c5 we looked at e3 now
and b6 here Bishop to e6 is again a
known move Peter like Oh plated against
Michael Adams Institute in 2014 in in
Dortmund that game also ended in a draw
but here we have b6 and it is a new
moving in the position so as of
move-move 16 we have a completely new
game so Bishop back the e3 maxime again
offers a trade we have Bishop captures
now you couldn't bring it back to East 7
but here to Paul of decides the trade
Bishop captures and now rook captures at
least you get the rook away from the D
file because it might be problematic if
white just is able to double up so
quickly on the D file with h6 taking
away the g5 Square from Mac seems night
and now rook to d1 and c5 the plan has
been achieved b65 you clear this
diagonal for the light square bishop and
now knight the age for now Maxime plan
is either he's gonna create a lot of
problems for black one when he brings
the knight over to f5 and I or or black
will have to give up the light square
bishop because if it isn't Bishop gets
on this diagonal will be a very useful
piece now it is possible to prevent the
knight from going to f5 by playing g6
but then you will have problems
defending the f7 point when this rook
comes to f3 so here after we have g5 top
olive even forces the Knight to a5 and
now he captures it and this is the
moment from the thumbnail so here there
are different options possible like
Bishop to e6 I just get the best part of
the way at Eden
defender to the if someone the problem
is after Knight to g7 you will still
have to give up the e6 Bishop it's
really not possible to defend it you
cannot capture on a two if you capture
then just be three and your bishop is
trapped
Roque one will just pick it up and if
you reach retreat with something like a
Bishop to d7 then again Luke f3 is very
strong you will have problems defending
this and now you have to repeat again
and now give up your Bishop rook f8
loses to just isa captures captures and
now you will not be able to recapture or
you lose the rook on f8 so it's a very
interesting moment where Bishop to e6 is
the best move but you have to allow
Knight to g7 and then just Knight
captures on e6 there there's no way
around it
so this is what you should to do however
top olive decided to play Bishop
captures an f5 we have G captures an f5
and now not only do a lot of whites to
very easily create a passed pawn here
but also White has a very clear plan
what to do white just wants to play
kingi to to f3 to g4 to h5 and then if
black does not want to part with the h6
pawn this rook pretty much has to stay
here and the guard the h6 pawn so King
b7 by top off prepares to bring the
artwork into the game kingi - now Maxime
starts the King March we have rook a to
d8 and Maxine just raised rook captures
rook captures and now King to f3 the
next part of the plan is well about to
be realized we have c4 and now comes rip
the e4 you don't want to allow the rook
to harass you after after you go King to
g4 we have b5 by to Paulo and now King
to g4
King to c8 and now e 6 even better if
you go king h5 you go into a race saying
that I'm gonna grab your points sooner
then you can clear all of my pawns but
Maxime says nope let's just go east 6
without giving black any time to
consolidate with F captors and e6f
captures and now look the h8 are
preparing to defend the h6 pawn with the
rook but now King the f5 we have king to
d8 and now Maxine just plays isse Evan
with check King to EA and here came to
g6 and
leave it or not it was in this position
that a vessel Interpol resigned the game
and this is exactly what I wanted to
show you this game because it is just
it's just very impressive how how easily
MVL accomplished a winning endgame and
how how the pall of decided that the
winning Indian was actually was in fact
not winning for for MVL but it was so
we're gonna discuss this position a bit
more in a second but after this Knight
to f5 move
you cannot capture this and allow this
this just this just gives a white - too
easy of a game to play even if it wasn't
objectively winning it's too easy to
play for white and it this is exactly
what happened
this is move 22 and the game ended and
move 36 so really really quick so not
it's just not not possible to play the
same game especially with the king still
being here you still have to waste a few
moves to get the rook into the game but
yeah the reason why after King to g6 the
power resign is you cannot allow King g7
this is just traps the Rope the Rope
will be without a square and doesn't
really matter what you play here if you
go rogue g8 check King h7 and now kink
the f7 then EA tween just goes into a
winning endgame for white characters
captures captures after teen captures an
age sex you're gonna grab this point and
then of course the to pass pawns are
winning the black points on the black
points on the Queen side will be much
too slow and also the King can easily
help out if needed because the the to
pass points on the King side will be on
a post and on the other hand after King
to g6 if you try something like King d7
to try and get your rook into the game
still doesn't really matter
King g7 rook e8 and now King to f7 you
just defend the pawn c5 or any other
move by black doesn't really matter
rook e1 and next move you're just gonna
go rook d1 check either the King moves
and you pick up the rook or the rook
moves but still now just go yet Queen
and it's just a UH nice e on Gustav's on
endgame where one player has a rook and
the other one doesn't of course
completely winning for MBL
so really impressive stuff and MVL gets
one step closer to his spot in the
candidates which eluded him for for so
long and I don't know if we'll be able
to cover the other
Game of the Rapids between the two of
them but just in case we don't MBL also
won that game so tupolev is eliminated
from the Jerusalem feeder Grand Prix
2019 and Maxime you know proceeds
further into the competition there are
some other games I've seen some very
interesting games and I hope to cover
them all so that's why I said I don't
know if I'll be have time to cover the
second game even though I do think it's
interesting but if it's really
interesting I will cover it that's
that's how it goes so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it you know don't go
into an end game like this seems like
especially if your play if you're a
Berlin player then you should know that
this is really bad for you I would like
to thank Matteo Bruno Johnny Adams
dhanunjay Bharadwaj
Carlos Carranza and Paul Boynton for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too in my previous video serum
think of for watching and I will see
soon continuing the coverage of the fede
grand prix 2019 the final leg of the
competition checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and as usual
checking up on whatever happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and do be a part of the
subscribers video see you soon